[Musique]
et si un jour vous devenez un playmobil
sans rire la titulaire le fait de jeu
flop je suis une basse et j'ai jusqu'à
ce soir pour sauver mon frère il vous me
le ramenait d'un coup de baguette
magique non donc votre frère a disparu
il y à peu près grand comme ça tu es
tout est
barbu qui change il disant je vais
contacter un petit peu partout adidas le
meilleur agent secret du monde
au cours de ces derniers mois un certain
nombre de citoyens se sont littéralement
volatilisée vous pensez que ce sont les
mêmes personnes qui m'ont enlevé mon
frère but considères tu devrais te
battre pour ta vie dans mon à rennes
on devrait bien s'amuser
jusqu'à ce soir pour sauver mon pru
encore du temps pour se décharger
avant ça tu dois te convaincre que tu en
es capable ici
des retards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les fans
le cheval
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bellerive elle arrive elle arrive elle
arrive
[Applaudissements]
oh